hello and welcome to my video series of
small bio explained
in three minutes where i explain a
concept of molecular biology in less
than three minutes or so if you
haven't yet subscribed hit that
subscribe button today we'll talk about
multiplex pcr the name suggests as if
performing many separate pcr reaction
all together
in one reaction right exactly
so multiplex pcr is the simultaneous
detection
of multiple targets in a single reaction
well
with a different pair of primer sets
for each target so let me tell you it in
a simpler way
so let's say in this pcr reaction tube
you want to detect
all these four targets so obviously
you can detect them by using
dedicated primer sets against them and
all of these is happening
inside one pcr machine one pcr tube
and when you run the gel you can
separate these products on the gel given
that they have
distinct size and there are many
criterias
which would be important for multiplex
pcr in this video we would learn about
that
so first let's learn what is
different in terms of a normal pcr
versus a multiplex pcr so let's set up a
multiplex pcr reaction so the biggest
difference is
the template dna so obviously here the
template dna would be from multiple
sources so you would expect different
type of targets present in that dna
obviously the forward and primer and the
reverse primer would be a combination of
many sets right so here there would be
several forward primers and several
reverse primers each dedicated to one
specific target
then dntp would be common tag polymerase
and
mgcl2 containing buffer would be
necessary just like any other pcr
reaction
now the key focus of this pcr process is
the forward and reverse primer sets
so few things we need to understand
while designing these kind of
pcr reaction first of all this forward
and reverse primer sets
should have same annealing temperature
during this pcr cycle
otherwise some would amplify and some
target would not be amplified
and that is not our goal we want all of
these targets to be amplified so
one particular optimum temperature need
to be
fixed and that can be achieved via
gradient pcr which i have discussed
earlier you can get the video in i
button then
the primer design should ensure that all
primers are highly highly specific
otherwise there could be a
misinterpretation and the amplicon size
should not differ too much because if
you have a big
amplicon versus a small amplicon then
the
polymerization time has to be optimized
in such a way
that both these targets can be amplified
not only one
and not the other so these are the
criteria that we need to understand
while setting up a multiplex pcr
so let's talk about some application of
multiplex pcr first of all pathogen
identification high throughput
genotyping mutation analysis gene
deletion analysis linkage analysis and
many more
so let me take one example and try to
explain it in a detailed way
so let's say you are infected by a
respiratory virus
now you can be infected by
a combination of many viruses right or
maybe one virus has infected you at that
point of time you want to
understand that which viruses has
infected you
and in order to understand that you are
going to get
your nasal swab done and from your nasal
swab rna would be extracted and cdna
would be prepared
and let's say in a diagnostic lab
they would test for virus a b c or d's
presence
now if virus a b and c d are present
then there would be respective
genes which are unique to them present
in this cdna sample right
exactly now from this sample
using unique primer set
all of these amplicons can be amplified
if these targets are present then there
would be a band if they are not present
then there would be no band
and that can be determined using this
pcr reaction
multiplexing ensures that with even
small amount of sample a lot of
information can be achieved
so this is a hypothetical result so here
look at these three patients in patient
one you would see
bands corresponding to all these vital
strains so if patient one is
unfortunately infected with all of these
viruses which could be dangerous
in contrast patient two and three are
selectively infected by
different viruses strain for example
patient 3 is infected by
only virus a strain and patient 2 is
infected with
only virus d and virus b strain not the
other ones
so multiplexing pcr can give us these
kind of advantages
that we have talked about so far so i
hope this video was informative if you
like this video give
it thumbs up don't forget to like share
and subscribe thank you